you
[Music]
with our busy lives in a fast-paced
world it's easy to dream of an escape
from it all for about a hundred people
that place is the Isle of egg in the
North Atlantic off the coast of Scotland
the islands residents prefer to live far
from modern life on the UK mainland
Steve Croft visited the island for
Sunday 60 minutes to see the appeal and
the unparalleled natural beauty here's a
preview just three miles wide six miles
long and ten miles off the Scottish
coast egg is part of the Inner Hebrides
surrounded by the Isles of rum muck and
sky at the edge of the North Atlantic
it's an ungroomed masterpiece of nature
too wild to take a craggy aisle of
incredible beauty populated mostly by
sheep and the dogs that keep track of
them the people do their best to stay
clear while taking everything in so
what's your average day like some people
would see very lazy I like to think I
just make the hard work luke easy all
depends on your look Charlie galley is
the taxi driver on egg and the only
source of public transportation up and
down the islands Feraud main artery
it's aneasha claim for himself when he
arrived from the mainland with his wife
and this aging Volvo four years ago
plenty of time to get the feel of the
place you know everybody on the island I
knew their minders true sizes and like I
say there's no secrets on an island so
so what are they talking about this week
mainly youth you can see Steve crops
full report Sunday night on 60 minutes
right here a hunt see forget the full
report I want to make the full move to
the island I see a reality TV show you
want people up in your bidness like that
I don't know you have an honeymoon yet
have I have not that could be a good
watch your shoe size